breaking news we've got man Steve
Connolly is missing the investigation
has been taken in this case hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play fabricant now it's
so good to have my voice back at a
hundred percent I haven't added at a
hundred percent in a long time so let's
destroy it by screaming at a scary game
now this game was oh it's dark um there
we
Oh what is wrong in my hand okay
whatever
okay press f to turn off and on your
lamp can I get that no okay so I haven't
been high water how are you doing well
has some hard water I can't even walk
around it it's also very loud the hell
okay then what am I supposed to do
alright anyway I got distracted oh oh
now I can get it Oh how'd alive
Oh close the door here how long is how
long was there a door here anyway I seem
to have jumped right into it I didn't
even have a chance to describe anything
a Hamar and a key can I get that hammer
okay apparently not okay ah makes total
sense okay now that all that craziness
is behind me let me give some like
backstory to this um there was a lot of
disclaimers saying that like the
developer really wanted to reiterate
that this game is in early beta but from
the screenshots it actually looked
pretty good I love that snowflake water
why is this Lantern not do anything at
all I can't see past my own face and I'm
about to run out of oil and there goes
good good good for me wandering around
in the darkness I guess I shouldn't have
had it on and they add lights right in
front of me okay this should be fun am i
moving forward
what the hell is that okay I think I see
uh something what is this what is this
in front of what what was that I can't
see a damn thing
it's a little too early for this don't
you think what is going on I think I huh
the door here please tell me there's
some storm huh I see something in the
darkness no that's a box okay anyway if
we could tone back a little bit I want
it oh hey look at that I'm not gonna
waste
I gotta waste it okay I got lantern oil
what's like em nurture okay so moving on
the backstory being I'm going into a
factory I keep it what though huh eyes
their teddy bear here okay
why okay
I'm starting to question things that I
probably what is that is that the water
please tell me that's the water over
there okay does that sound okay I'm not
looking oh oh that would have been
nearly impossible to find I'm a genius
good thing I'm so great at these horror
games
oh come on these looks like places for
torches but I don't see anything
gotta put my microwave being too loud my
voice is back 200 so the hours have
passed and I'm still walking and I
wonder if I will even come out of this
tunnel I'm really freaked out when I was
walking around these tunnels I've heard
voices and the strange sounds something
is wrong in this place but I have not
given up yet the journey has already
started the journey to why the journey
to word the journey to crapping my pants
which I don't have on at the moment okay
oh nice water physics time to escape
what do you mean no throw that at me
what are you talking about you gave him
one let's get some wine oh the water is
rising oh okay oh that makes so much
more sense okay that's not like there
was a monster by me or something get out
of the way you tube a barrel okay can i
lantern stay on for like two seconds
thank you very much oh I am going to die
aren't I I'm gonna drown a horrible
death at least I'm not dying by the
hands of some diabolical demonic monster
hello
Galloway got away hard water down oh I
get it I get it
ah no what are you doing what are you
doing what am i doing what am i doing
there's nothing here ah come on
I have drowned but how was I supposed to
be able to not drown that is the
question isn't it
all right back into it okay so I'm
looking for like a button or something I
don't know something to turn off that
water over there but I didn't even see a
door like before there was a door to a
pipe that you could twisty knob thingy
to get it to not do any of that just
guessing I need to go backwards once I
get to a certain point down all right
okay
where are we going now oh what the no
this wasn't here before
y'all tell me this randomly generated
all the Sun was this explosives house I
can el me get this camera out camera get
that thing out whatever I'm doing I
don't know what I'm doing here game has
dragged through all mechanics oh no that
means I'm trying it not doing I'm not
doing I'm putting down both buttons it
ain't doing nothing it ain't doing jack
doodly-squat it ain't doing nothing Hey
oh nothing I do not like You sam-i-am
I do not like green eggs and you move
over there stay out of my way just stay
out of my way where the hell did I go
the first time that suddenly I need it
oh I need to uh I need to pick this up
and chuck it at it that's what I need to
do okay get out of my way and ladder to
escape that's lovely
yay I did it I fine I finally found the
exit from tunnels now I'm on a factor
okay
screwing anybody home
any diabolical demons they want to scare
the pants off of me
too late they're already off did I
mention that already I don't play games
with pants on for multiple reasons okay
where am I now
outside hem are finally picked up the
hammer some common sense in my brain
hole oh this looks lovely finally we're
at that this is the better side of the
[ __ ] okay I didn't want to read that
anyway because I need to read fast but
in the intro was it your stay on for two
jacket who stay a little bit was that
sound hello hello what's going on in
there can I get in
can I see who's in there alright let's
be a bit expeditious about this why is
this not opening I have a hammer could I
have our it off no do I need to throw
something at it possibly let's just
carry on this way I know why the lantern
kept drawing it wasn't the game it was
um it was up every time I press shift
which I'm a [ __ ] sprinter it drops
the lantern okay all right now I think
we might be getting into the
nitty-gritty oh okay all right so I do
have to get in here somehow I couldn't
get in through the front the big wooden
gate thingy thingy does that sound
was that like a sick moose what's going
on in there what is that
I would I would like to know what it is
before I blindly wander into it
Oh what I did that a thousand times okay
could I cut uh thank you got a ladder
what is that what is anything you just
did a noise in my ear then appreciate it
I never appreciated garden gate key
right okay listen pretend like I never
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever am going in there I don't
even know what that was I don't even
have a guess for what that was if I had
to guess sound like some hot wood on
wood action this is Gepetto's new
workshop and he made Pinocchio a hooker
and little wooden hook okay place ladder
up there oh I already did apparently yay
boy this game sure makes me feel
accomplished about the things that I do
when I'm struggling to survive okay is
that how you want to play this oh isn't
this just a lie excuse me it's a flare
see ah candelabra do Turney
that ha I really don't want know what to
do every day I'm getting reports of
vanishing workers my factory is going to
go bankrupt
it seems the history tends to repeat
itself many years ago in 1892 the
previous owner and founder of the
factory went bankrupt and because of his
big debt who has committed suicide
really is that what he has do ah aren't
I just a genius smartypants now let's
see if I can find what to do with it key
to this door ah
does it do you just one junker and
that's it by fine be that way okay okay
alright I was just starting to get into
it with it was a little frustrating in
the beginning but then it started get
good but uh well so uh huh could be
potential there I see some potential
later on it was a little frustrating in
the beginning because I don't think it
was enough time to learn what you wanted
me to do like III know it said that you
could throw objects but it went by
quickly and I wasn't reading it so that
might be my fault that might be my fault
pretty much everything in this could be
explained to my fault or me nagging it
like it was pretty good like that scare
got me but that's all I gotta say so
thank you all so much for watching link
to the game is in the description below
give it a try and as always I'll see you
in the next one
do I
Oh God okay
Wow